روسيا تسلم حليفتها اسلحه قوتها اكبر من
قنبله هيروشيما
اول تعليق من والد نيره اشرف المكلوم بعد
اعدام قاتلها
بلجيكي يقيم جنازته قبل وفاته والسبب يثير
ضجه واسعه
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فهلا بكم
اعلن الرئيس بيلاروسيا الكسندر لوكشينكو
ان بلاده بدات بالفعل تسلم الاسلحه
النوويه التكتيكيه الروسيه تمهيدا لنشرها
على اراضي بلاده وذكر احاليف زعيم
الكرملين ان بعض هذه الاسلحه اقوى بثلاث
مرات من القنبلتين ذريتين اللتين القتهما
الولايات المتحده على هيروشيما وناجازاكي
باليابان في عام 1945
اتت هذه التطورات بعد اشهر من اعلان بوتين
ستنشر اسلحه نوويه التكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا
الواقعه على ابواب الاتحاد الاوروبي ما
اثر انتقادات دوليه ومخاوفه من تصعيد
للنزاع في اوكرانيا
بعد نحو سنه على الحادثه التي هزت العالم
العربي اصدر الستار على فاجعه مقتل طالبه
المنصوره نيره اشرف ذبحا في محافظه
الدقهليه بتنفيذ حكم الاعدام بحقيقهلها
محمد عادل وفي اول تعليق اكد والد نيره
لموقع القاهره 24 ان ابنته سترقد بسلام
اليوم بعدما تم القصاص من قاتلها قائلا ان
ابنته لن تعود للحياه الثانيه الا ان حقها
اليوم وصل اليها وهي في مرقدها يشار الى
ان الجريمه كانت هزت الشارع المصري باكمله
لفضاعتها خصوصا ان القاتله طعن زميلته
امام باب الجامعه وعلى مراه الجميع
اخبار الفضاء اتمت شركه سبيس اكس الهبوطه
رقم 200 لصاروخ فالكون تسعه وكانت الشركه
التي اسسها ويراس مجلس ادارتها الملياردير
الامريكي ايلون ماسك قد اطلقت 72 قمرا
صناعيا صغيرا الى الفضاء لبدء مهمه مشاركه
تدعى
ثمانيه واوضح بيان رسمي لسبيس اكس ان
الشركه تجاوزت مرحله الاخطاء في هبوط
واقلاع الصواريخ الفضائيه كما تمكنت في
الشركه من خفض تكلفه رحلات الفضاء ناهيك
عن زياده وتيره عمليات الاطلاق والتقليل
من التلوث البيئي
نبقى في اخبار الفضاء فبعد ان كانت تلك
محصوره بافلام الخيال العلمي شهدت الصين
تحليقه اول طبق طائر في مدينه تشانزن في
اول مشهد من نوعه في العالم صحيفه
البريطانيه اوضحت ان الطائره بل الطبقه
الطائر الذي جرى تصويره في الصين لغرض
السياحه ياتي دائري الشكل وتتوسطه كبسوله
زجاجيه في الوسط ومن مزايا تلك المركبه
التي تعمل بالطاقه الكهربائيه انها تقلع
بشكل سلس كما انها تستطيع ان تهبط على
الارض والماء على حد سواء
نختم نشرتنا من بلجيكا حيث قام صانع محتوى
تيك توك يدعى بالتعاون مع عائلته بترويج
خبر كاذب بشان وفاته على مواقع التواصل
صحيفه ديلي ميل اوضحت انه اثناء مراسم
دفنه الوهميه فاجا ديفيد الحاضرين في
جنازته حين هبط بواسطه طائره مروحيه فيما
اثار هذا المقلب جدلا واسعا على السوشيال
ميديا بين مرحبين ومنتقدين واصرح ديفيد ان
هدفه من زيف وفاته كانت بمثابه درسنا لانه
علم لاحقا ان نصف اقربائه لم يحضروا
الجنازه
[موسيقى]